you can swing a fine fancy though what
uh what do you think of it uh it's good
um definitely better than 15 that's for
sure it's most certainly a game but you
would not enjoy oh well I enjoyed the
first two hours and then I did another
stream playing it for two hours that was
sponsored yeah it was fine but I I don't
know if I'm gonna continue yeah because
I want to play the other final fantasies
first yeah I mean I know I know you
finished the final fantasies
I I think when I went into it I liked
the fast-paced combat we played eight I
like the eight yeah I like the part of
me as much as I hate turn-based combat
it's kind of nice sometimes really you
should play 10 next I hate it in modern
games because I feel like it's outdated
right yeah I just said in Pokemon where
it just feels like it walks
um so do you want to go back to like the
first couple of final fans yeah I'm
gonna play some of them play six
everyone says six I feel like six I
should play I've played some of the
other ones because everyone says in all
the Final Fantasy staff are like six is
the accumulation of the perfect Final
Fantasy it is and I'm like okay well
I'll save that then I'm
yeah then maybe play like yeah probably
play Four first then yeah
ones seemed tough to get into
they seem like it's like one like a slog
I'm not gonna lie yeah they can't be
what uh what didn't draw you in about
this Final Fantasy Final Fantasy 16. I
don't know it's on paper I'm like this
is very I mean it's not that I didn't
draw me in it's just I I think that it's
a lot and I was like I also I think uh
well I don't even know what I don't even
know what I can say because I was
sponsored by them I don't always get
pissed off okay sometimes I did feel
like it was like I could put my
controller down and then I when I had to
pick it back up I was like oh [__] it's
a game yeah that was like I was like oh
[__] no because yeah because they the
the producers of cut scenes yeah
okay now now I understand the producer
actually said before the game came out
that this was supposedly the most
cinematic it is I almost they weren't
lying I almost like wish and I know that
there is an easy story mode but like
there was a version of it that was just
like a 17 hour show yeah yeah that like
didn't require you to put any input
because I actually actually like I found
myself getting really into the cutscenes
and then I was like oh [__] I gotta play
and it was fun it was great but it was
like it was like oh
I was like I'm just getting confused
with the fact that I was like oh yeah I
gotta I gotta keep playing it's an
actual game yeah it's pretty interesting
I mean it was it was very it was very
interesting because I think that it's
it's for me it I think it'll lend itself
well and history as being a great
in-between point for the series yes yeah
I think it'll lead to like 17 being like
figuring out a formula that really works
but I don't know if having that many
cutscenes is good for a game I it I'm
torn as well because even me I [__]
love the cutscenes I love voice
so it's it's so surreal just seeing like
a jrpg without like let's say the
typical anime-esque voice actors and
just saying like do you mean Xenoblade
yes yes Joey or any jrpg
yeah and the and hearing actual British
voice actors but either there are like
some moments in the game where
um I like the gameplay and I really
really like the story I don't know if it
wants to be a game or a movie they made
this the cutscenes too damn good yeah
they did to the point where it's like
damn that's the that's like I'm so hyped
for the cutscene so when I go in the
gameplay yeah like I said like it's like
oh [__] okay yeah yeah I want more of
the cutscenes yeah it's it's weird
because like I really really for example
like Metal Gear Solid right the medical
solid series who
that those cut scenes were so long that
I could just put my controller down and
just zoom out for like 30 minutes I was
like I'm fine with that I'm totally fine
on that it's so weird with Final Fantasy
because the cutscenes are short enough
that I still have to pay attention about
the controller but it's long enough that
it kind of like breaks the flow of like
the gameplay I think the one issue I
have with 16 is that like I don't mind
cutscenes in my video games as long as
you're telling you know as long as it's
for a purpose and you know the narrative
is good which so far with 16 has been
great but I think my problem with 16
right now is that like the the I guess
the switching between cutscene and
playable part of the game is so like
constant yeah where it's like you know
there'd be moments where it's like okay
you get out of a you enter a village
there's a cut scene that like explains
the village and the main quest and then
you walk for 15 seconds and then another
cutscene plays and then you walk another
15 seconds and then another cutscene
plays where it's like
just give me one long
and then one long gaming session and
then I'll be good I also I I like it but
I don't know how to feel about it I like
the active law button where you can just
you're like him you're like I don't know
what the [__] is going on in the story
let me hold down this button and it
brings up a menu that'll that you can
it'll you can move your like cursor over
it and it'll tell you about what this
concept is or what this faction is or
who you have to be careful with that
because it's awesome stuff yeah I've
heard from people like especially near
like the last 10 of the game that part
just straight up has spoil isn't it I
believe it yeah I mean I've been trying
to avoid as much as possible I mean I
think it's a game changer because
especially at the beginning where they
just introduce you to all these all of
these like countries and people and uh
characters and I'm like I can't remember
who the [__] this is in this time skips
and stuff and you're like okay this is
it's like being thrown into Game of
Thrones at like like well I mean
actually being a Thrones Game of Thrones
uh because you're just like what the
hell is happening but in Game of Thrones
of the time to go through all of it yeah
and I feel like they may be and I
remember the story time is a little bit
more they introduced things a little bit
better and Final Fantasy the one thing I
did with the new one I found to struggle
with was that there was there was too
much stuff that I was trying to keep
track of and I didn't quite understand
and that's why the active law button
felt necessary whereas I feel like it
shouldn't be necessary but a nice little
thing if I want to refresh yeah but a
lot of the time I found myself having to
do it I think the active law thing
though is definitely a good step and
direction of like explaining law without
having these like [__] Pages without
having to like go to a system and like
the log and [__] to be like here's like
a [__] drop down menu of everything
you know where it's like I'm actually
that guy [__] why okay so how do you
hate yourself when because I was genuine
like when I uh one one reasons I [__]
love Final Fantasy 16 is because like
the world genuinely genuinely it's great
yeah no it's great it's [__] great
and I just wanted to be immersed so as
soon as like there's a character in like
your hideout that basically has like the
is the law keeper and that like has all
of the wiki articles and I literally
just wasted I think in like an hour and
a half when that opened up just like
reading just like reading everything
just so I can just immerse myself in
what was going on
I think my biggest problem with it so
far I'm about like 20 hours in at the
time recording uh there just hasn't been
a character that I have fallen in love
with yeah yeah normally in a jrpg I've
fallen in love with the cast and the the
Dynamics and you know just spending time
with these characters but so far there
just hasn't been like the characters
haven't called out to me yet I mean I
did have one but uh he didn't last long
I mean without key foilers I just feel
like there hasn't been enough let's say
like the main story I I feel like the
biggest weakness of Final Fantasy has
actually been so far the side quests
because side quests yeah the Side Quests
for this one are a little bit boring
yeah the side quest for me in like
especially in jrpgs is a great way to
just to just ignore the story or ignore
the main story for a bit and just flesh
out these characters hanging out
together yeah and um just uh exploring
like and expanding the world and giving
you the opportunity to learn about the
the world and the characters organically
yeah and all of the side quests so far
has just been fetch Quest and there's
been like pick up dirt yeah pick up dirt
go find this person Assassin's Creed
style yeah it is
kill five crabs and it's just like I
don't get anything more from doing these
side quests if I had not done it yeah so
it's just been like the main story for
me and the main story is great but the
main story so far has not given me
enough time with these characters enough
banter enough just natural chemistry
from each like get attached to like the
whole cast and I don't know if that's
going to change I hope it does uh but
that's like my biggest gripe with Final
Fantasy